my scanners picking up a new dimension
oh no wait just a speck on the screen
never mind
so yeah this is an example of the scope
of an adventure ha they're taking Marty
in here Marty's got his electric guitar
so what sort of activities can you do it
on in a venture world you're going to
park and walking out apart from rotten
air apart from traveling in time well
here we're going to we can explore we
can collect Lego studs there are serious
side quests and are optional quests are
offered to you by different characters
there's a race you can see that terminus
gate way over there that will give us
access to race we're successful give us
a gold brick gold bricks then used to
give new abilities powers of different
partners so the lots of interlocking
progression mechanics throughout the
game lots of hidden areas you can just
double with with different characters
and in this particular danger your
actions in the past kind of alter things
in the future so we're actually going to
have to travel in time that was my very
next question what happens when you hit
88 miles he'll let the flame let's find
out okay so you can see right now we're
Caesar speedometers Congress rocketing
up now we're getting up some power we're
going to hit Big O
so are we able to go to the three time
periods back to the future and of course
you know the love that the team has for
all these movies and properties and
characters and universes means that the
nothing is off-limits and the diligence
which they have done everything you
would expect so yeah not only can they
go to the past but of course the rules
the future and ride a hoverboard
so there are noodle new quests and you
know things two things to discover here
and again as before you can bring in
different different characters so we
could drop out then we could drop out
with which the West and we could put in
scooby-doo and unikitty from the lego
movie and each got their different
abilities we're not going to build a
Scooby Snack
cool cool though that is we could have
Scooby riding in the DeLorean oh that's
right so those that's one of the reasons
why you collect the Lego studs
throughout the game trigger and build so
with Scooby here we can summon the
DeLorean and then Scooby kill drivers
going around he's scared of that
great for driving and paralyzed
and then one of my personal favorite
characters and the game is voiced across
thousands of free and unique abilities
not only is to to shoot rainbow lasers
but actually if she gets really super
angry you'll remember she's rainbow
lasers and chops down so you know that
sense of exploration and discovery that
what would happen here and what could
this have in common we always try to go
the extra mile really surprise you both
to preparations